do you know how many people will tell
you they don't like oysters but have
never had one a lot of people I really
do think exploring and curiosity is a
topic that we need to talk more about
maybe you've been looking for a sign
because you're a guidance counselor but
you've always wanted to do acting in
theater and like maybe you should just
go across the street and go to the local
theater or whatever it is right like
people are incredibly limited and I
really do think that curiosity is the
underrated human trait right now
attention is the number one
asset vayer Nation uh it is very
actually it's not that rare but you know
it's not every day we get to have a
legend in the building with us on the
podcast and they'll be coming after this
podcast yeah so you looking around
they're coming an hour after but this is
the precursor uh William H Macy
obviously I know a lot of you are
incredibly familiar with his work and
just genuinely incredibly respected for
his craft what's fun about this is he
walks into the office for this podcast
with with his entrepreneurial hat on and
we're going to dig in here and I think
why I was excited to do this is not only
to to get a brief moment with somebody
that I respect a lot and get to say
thank you for the work B I know that the
audience is going to love this because I
know how loved he is but see I think
it's important to reinforce something
I'm passionate about which is just
having a multi-dimensional life
especially in today's world so many of
us you and I are part of a generation
where like you know pre you know we grew
up without the internet uh and so the
internet has created a world where just
people's ability to do multiple things a
renaissance man um is so real and I
think it's kind of powerful weal I talk
a lot about it with maybe people on
podcast or on my content that maybe
aren't as well known but I think it's
actually incredibly powerful to know
that people that have even gotten to the
highest levels of their craft in a
public environment also have other
aspects other interests and we're
luckily we're all living longer yeah I
think about that a lot you know like the
you know the kids that are 15 17 now
they're going to live to 110 20 like
it's crazy what's going on with modern
medicine and how we're getting educated
with food supply and things of that
nature and true so I just think this
will be a fun uh episode and William
thank you for being on well thank you so
much and um yeah you're right this is a
brand new thing for me uh my wife says
that it's important that we frighten
ourselves all the time do something
you're not used to so I've jumped off
the deep end here and uh I joined Woody
Creek distillers because Mark clner and
uh they live next door to me oh no
kidding Pat and Mary and Mark and me
right next door to each other love that
where in Woody Creek I live in Woody
Creek and so how long had you been there
or when did you guys meet into who's
been there how long how break that down
for me well so uh we we really started
the The Distillery in Earnest in 2010 as
we were researching my partner and I
were really into drinking chopan B
potato b m and we were going to make an
American chopan plus love it in that
little Valley and you know just five
miles from Aspen used to crank out more
potatoes than the entire anybody I'm
aware back turn of the century turn of
the last century by the way apologize
for interrupting you that analogy there
is a big driver of me I think history
has a lot of innovation in it and when
you hear that hey did you know that this
little Valley pumped out more potatoes
than so a lot of how I innovate is based
on history so for a lot of you that have
passions and things you know especially
now with AI which is like 10 times more
powerful than search asking questions to
give permission notice how that was said
this Valley pumped out more potatoes
than I now that's giving permission to
like why it could make great potato
vodka and I think there's a billion
things like that out there so toay
curious and look for those historical
permission points but keep going yeah so
uh from 2010 to 2012 before we got our
licenses and started making moves we
were growing different varietal of
potatoes looking for land and uh Mr Macy
here living next door to me happened to
have a couple nice pastures that were
nice and flat and well irrigated and uh
knew each other a little bit as
neighbors but then uh so we he knocked
well he knocked on your door and said I
want to your land you want to be the
spokesperson and I said
sure you be part of this and so this
started as early as 2012 or so was a
little bit later we started producing
alcohol in 2012 found out very quickly
when you're making a potato vodka you
want to use a fresh potato right out of
the ground so we're ourselves uh mashing
5 10 tons a day rinse repeat and uh once
from maybe September through November we
make our vodka then we're done and we're
like okay now what we do let's make
whiskey so the other nine months we we
started cranking whiskey uh the Vodka
2015 double gold San Francisco Spirits
comp best overall Spirit following year
the the Ry got the double gold and uh so
pretty much I think we know what we're
doing and Bill's Bill's been there from
the get-go this is not a celebrity brand
in any way he's a passionate partner
bill is that because he doesn't think
you're a celebrity or I'm not sure yeah
was I was just trying to follow the
the vi there I do have to sweep things
like actually we'll get back let's we'll
bounce back to the alcohol in a minute
obviously so many of you know I I grew
up in this industry and so um it's been
really cool to see brown Goods make a
comeback I got involved in my dad's
liquor store when I was 14 stock in
shelves and I caught the tail end of the
brown Goods era I'm just going to break
this down for everyone who's listening I
know how cool and trendy you know
whiskies and and all and Rise are now
they were the dominant force in the the
Mad Men era the 50s 60s '70s everybody
drank it and then I my ironically my
entire uh spirits and wine and beer
career in retail was the one window when
they were super down right when I was 14
people would come in and buy door Scotch
we would sell hundreds of cases of door
scotch and fr Angelica and baile it was
Lor Lor Lor and then a I took my dad's
business to a wine Direction but B it
became more about vodka absolute vodka
and then Grey Goose blew the lid off the
door and then all the others and then
Tios had its run but and then I kind of
started this marketing company in in 09
but full-time 2011 and by like 2013 145
the papies and all this movement started
happening so it's really interesting to
see the brown Goods game so we'll go
back to that ad minute but Bill real
quick just to while we've got you on the
podcast like what what is when people
ask you about your career in acting if
if we're accepting that you are a
celebrity
um there's a lot of people that listen
to this podcast who and you know this
with the new world of social media
people are able to get exposure out of
at home with one video which is
obviously very different than the
industry you grew up in where people had
to do a lot of things often before they
even got to La often before they even
got the Serendipity of Discovery
thinking about the incredible craft that
Woody Creek brings to its
category what what is the when you think
about the craft of acting or creating or
performing what's your observation of
the new world that we now live in where
everyone has a platform everyone has the
opportunity and and just to give you
into what I do for a living what's
changed with social media in the last 15
years has even more interesting the last
2 three years what's happened is the way
social worked from 2010 to
2020 was or 2005 to 2020 was you had to
make content and people had to follow
you almost like a newsletter for like an
email they would follow you and then a
percentage of them would see every time
you would post like an email right not
everybody would open it today's social
media we now live in the algorithms it
explodes correct you know I
grinded for 15 I did a wine show M four
bottles just like what we're set up
right now four bottles of wine in front
of a camera for 15 to 20 minutes a day
from 2006 to 2011 5 days a week for five
straight years to get a somewhat base
that I then built on sure today
literally today as we sit here somebody
will make their first ever video on Tik
Tok and it will get 3 million views and
they will be Off to the Races now that's
a needle in a Hy stack but it happens
those needles are happening every day
I'm I'm think about all this stuff well
I'm aware that social media is important
and it's how we're going to sell more of
the Woody Creek products but uh it's
interesting true the uh you ask about
the craft of acting uh really what I do
for a moment yes is seconds you know I
have one moment and when I finish that
you do the next moment when you finish
enough moment you've done Hamlet but
it's the micro and what I love about
Woody Creek distillers is that yeah we
were into we're into social media but um
what it really comes down to is a
process of distilling these things uh as
best as can be done and one of the
things I love about it is the process
hasn't changed and it it's the same old
thing it's the same old thing it's just
RIT large with science you should see
our Distillery it's stunning oh it's
it's but it's the same thing you go back
to the basic the uh the fals yes it's
the fundamentals are you sad that with
science I'm very sad about what I'm
about to say and I'm really not sad it's
a silly ideology but I think it's with
the advancements in science in both
spirits and wine it's getting harder to
[__] it up yeah I liked that PE humans
used to make tons of mist I mean there
used to be very bad wine even when I was
a kid getting in the game you had bad
years because we didn't know the weather
well enough and you just might wake up
and it haes and you're crushed whereas
now like the even even predicting the
weather is so Advanced by comparison of
even 30 years ago yeah even though the
weather man still the best gig you're
always wrong and everyone's like Yay
still possible to make some Monumental
mistakes it is but it is right it's been
mitigated traumatically you're you're
you're when you said you should see our
Distillery a lot in that has changed in
the science go ahead there's there's
less art it's a little more
manufacturing automation
and the implementation automation
distilleries and whatnot yeah you're not
going to have those man-made errors
happening things are automated and 100%
yep talk to me about your journey with
beverages just for a little fun um as a
kid milk or water soda as a we're going
way back as a child not soda not milk no
I'm not a sugar guy okay even as a kid
even as a kid where where did you grow
up I grew up in Cumberland Marland okay
Maryland where Ry whiskey was King the
manaila river and my parents drank rye
and um I went through a period of loving
Scotch whiskies all of them um the
thicker the better and
uh and uh I started in in my 20s and 30s
yeah I still like of course does you're
allowed to like other things besides
what you said when I joined the
Distillery I I
rediscovered rye whiskey yep cuz I I'm a
southern boy I was born in Georgia and
uh uh I was bourbon but Ry whiskey is my
passion now and that's what my signature
whiskey is it's it was a blind tasting
of barrel tasting so I was surprised
when I chose something that's 80% Ry and
20% malt and that's what this is here
that's it and so you do you do that
every year you'll pick the barrel you
most like this was the first year I hope
I do some more
um it was a magnificent experience
because uh Woody Creek distillers is
very small there I bet you there were
seven or eight people that decide what
goes out it's not focus groups and stuff
like that it's family it's craft family
business yep everything is designed to
make the best Spirits possible um and we
you know you got to be Savvy about
social media and and advertising your
target audience but I think it's a bad
bad thing when that starts to drive the
process I think the process should be
it's that old adage right if I listen to
My Consumer I'd made a a faster horse
there you go yeah I understand talk to
me about your pallet uh on non-alcoholic
stuff currently what beverages do you
drink that are not Woody
Creek um that aren't alcohol tea um I'll
have a tea every once in a while but I
do love to put a little bourbon or rye
and call it a hot TI but that's a cup of
tea y um water yeah I drink a lot of
water I'm pretty healthy I love my
coffee I'm a snob about the bruise that
I use we've got this brevel machine it
takes a long time to make it I know I
have it as well but Lord I get excited
about my cup of coffee the night you you
pick you pick your beans like your yep
so you've got a little bit of that wine
DNA in your
coffee yeah I guess I do I don't
understand that but yes what I mean by
that is C you know I've always found
coffee most similar to wine where like
you're really getting down to the
patches of land the coffee beans from
Ethiopia you know in wine world like you
can literally cross the street in
burgundy yeah you can literally cross a
street and one Wine's 40 bucks and the
other one's 8,000 yeah you know the Tera
changes so quickly just in such a short
and this goes back to potatoes 100% like
what people don't understand like vodka
is a tricky game people talk about it
doesn't taste different it tastes
different it's scary to me that the
first four years of tasting wine from 21
to 25 I'm talking I was tasting 2550
wines a day building my pallet cuz this
was my passion I remember calling my mom
about a year in when I was 22 and
remember I've been reading since I was
14 so I knew everything mhm I could tell
you everything but I remember about a
year in I called my mom and I'm like Mom
this isn't going to work out I was
really distraught I was like it just all
tastes like wine you know I'm reading
these reviews chocolate and Gooseberry
and raspberry I'm like what the [__] I'm
like there's Mom it just tastes like red
wine and then I remember calling her 6
months later actually the moment
happened I remember I was in a
restaurant in Scotch Plains New Jersey
doing a tasting of a portfolio yeah and
I tasted an
amaroni and when I tasted it it tasted
like a Snickers bar not like red wine
and I ran out this I just got in the
cell phone I ran out of the place called
my mom I said Mom we're good all right I
just tasted chocolate in an Italian red
wine and and from that day forward to
where I today and I find myself on a
similar Journey with other beverages of
All Sorts it's very easy for me to taste
subtleties um and I always tell people
when they're like I don't get it I'm
like think of the thing you drink the
most do you think you can taste the
difference and for a lot of people it's
water the amount of people that like are
deeply passionate about their watero
tastes different than you know this and
and that's what these that's where it
gets fun when you you know for a lot of
people who've never had a rye well
truthfully I give them four they're like
this tastes the same for someone like
you you could taste them all differently
I don't have the pette for it when we
did a blind tasting yes I wrote nice
sense of humor I didn't know what else
to write you know I love that uh yeah I
I don't get it and sometimes it feels
silly to me but um it turns out I know
what I like I just don't have the words
for it yet well you know what's funny
you the sentence you just Del for
everyone who's listening if you go on
your journey with Rye or Bourbons or
whiskies or scotch or anything wine tea
coffee the biggest issue I had in the
wine world when I was in it was people
are intimidated by it I've seen people
who like are Titans of Industry get to a
fancy restaurant and pass the wine list
as quick as they can because they don't
want to make the wrong choice and I
always found that fascinating because in
food nobody's embarrassed that they're
ordering the lobster and not the steak
or this kind of pasta but for some
reason in the upper echelons of
alcoholic beverages there's this
pretentiousness of like well you don't
get it you don't you don't understand
this you're ordering a Jack Daniels
that's not good stuff compared to I get
it I find it very like oh yeah wrong I
think what you just said is the most
right Journey now the key that everybody
screws up in my opinion is if they like
something whiskey wine they find one
they like and then they drink it every
exclusiv correct that kills me the the
game is cool you found a thing you like
go explore for a little bit of a journey
find your core go-tos but always mix it
up a little bit because it actually
makes you appreciate your go your core
go-to as well but you're right it gets
so precious sometimes I mean sometimes
you know they bring the wine if it's a
red wine I'll taste it if it's a white
wine and it's not expensive I say just
pour it yeah exactly just pour it it's
okay you can calm down well it's funny
I'm sure for you living in the Hollywood
world and the high-end Spirits world
there's I'm sure settings you've been in
where you're not sure which one's more
douchy right no seriously I've been to a
ton of pre you know like this is a
category I love Yeah but like I'm very
passionate about the craft of especially
the products that you you two represent
those small batch family you're going to
get some real stuff same with wine
because I'm very passionate about it but
man 98% of the events I go to in both
sectors everyone's just trying to outdo
each other as if as if their pallets
more right than yours to your point you
this is why I'm hanging on this everyone
whatever it is as long as you like it
that's the win listen to your explore
things that's the thing I worry about
when people are like well I like it no
no you got to explore because then you
actually know if you like it I went to
the uh we did this magnificent
motorcycle trip and we were in Berlin
for the big liquor show there huge but
they were selling things
like garbage garbage Spirits it was made
from garbage and they there was other
stuff they were in oil cans everybody
like doing backflips to try to rise
above the den and sell something but
just at a point it gets silly of course
it gets silly that's like humans are
incredibly capable of siling up things
yeah you know the other thing for
everyone who's listening I'm going to
use my
oysters uh uh thesis which is I the
oyster thesis here wa yep you're going
to like this because I think this may
get people to go out and discover your
product uh as we talk about a bourbon a
bourbon whiskey ay whiskey and some B
then there's a Jin here by the way I
want to get into that in a minute CU
I've been waiting for 20 years for it to
have its moment um and I think it's
really underrated and really flexible
and like I I'm just curious if we're
ever going to I don't know if it's a
subconscious bias against the Brits I'm
just just waiting for America to get
serious about JY uh but
um the oysters
oysters bill yeah do you know how many
people will tell you they don't like
oysters but have never had one a lot of
people yes sir and who can blame them
they look scary yes I'm empathetic to
the hypothesis that leads one there MH I
also have really enjoyed the last 10
years of my life getting people to try
their first one m and literally seeing
one out of every two loving it and one
out of every two punching me directly in
the face cuz it was the worst thing that
ever happened to them this is where I'm
going a little bit in the context here
if you're listening right now uh I I I
really do think exploring and curiosity
is a topic that we need to talk more
about and I think it comes in all shapes
and sizes when I think about who's
listening to this podcast maybe you've
been looking for a sign because you're a
guy in it's counselor but you've always
wanted to do acting in theater and like
maybe you should just go across the
street and go to the local the local
theater or whatever it is ABS right like
maybe this was the moment cuz you love
this guy and you're like this is the
sign why is Gary having Willam on
podcast I'm gonna go number two if you
only drink
tequila that's all you drink it's the
only thing you like and I know that it
doesn't give me a hang I hear it every
day but as someone who 25 years ago was
sad that nobody in America drank good
tequila I'm now sad that people only Dr
tequila so if you're listen right now
and and it's awesome and it's great that
you love tequila but to go on a journey
especially for producers like Woody
creekers that that are doing the
handcrafted thing go out and try like
cool like if if it's too hot too much
alcohol not the flavor good news take a
sip and move on yeah but it's the
oysters thesis it's a big world it is a
big world I was in I was Paris with my
daughter she was 10 years old and she
ordered the snails my wife and I said
okay okay all right so she got the
snails she took a bite I said what do
you think she said it's good if you like
soil it's true she finished them uh fun
fact I ate like 40 es pieces of escaro
Saturday Night 40 yeah I'm obsessed with
escargo there's a joke there somewhere I
there's definitely a joke there
somewhere um yeah no es cargo like food
is fascinating like people are
incredibly Limited
and I really do think that curiosity is
the underrated human trait right now
people have become incredibly siloed and
um I think there's some coolness to that
being into something but expanding
matters you talk about Jen I'm a huge
fan of Jen and we have a um Mary's Jin
it's called it's a blue Jin with a
butterfly pea flow in it oh my lord it's
so good it's so good when when how do
you like to drink your Jin straight I'm
AIC guy but also just on the rocks with
a little squeeze of lemon how do you
drink yours I most of my spirits I like
mixing them with ice cubes yeah that's
pretty much the big the big circle Ice
Cube yeah I like that too like there's
something about a big Cube yeah right I
feel like it's an American thing we like
everything like right like super size
like these no but the big ice cube does
like add to the experience oh it totally
does I mean if you think about it it's
one of the major components
of course so the ice has to be right it
can be too wet you know what's funny a
couple years ago probably towards the
tail end of me being in a being in a
liquor store dayto day is when I started
to see premium tonic you know my whole
career at my dad's store was Canada Dry
tonic 99 Cents plastic whatever and then
you started seeing the high-end tonic
and you know in business meetings around
the world um I I don't do Jin often I I
predominantly do wine but when I go
Spirits I I I eat my own dog food so
what I was just saying is I'll go
exploring and that and it mattered like
I remember 15 20 years ago was when I
found Japanese whiskey mhm and like now
in The Last 5 Years it's gotten super
uber collectible and people are
passionate but it was very clear to me
the craft and the quality of those
products 20 25 years ago um I but the
gin and tonic thing the premium tonic
thing really actually matters I remember
two or 3 years ago some into some cool
Speak Easy they it was a real setup and
I actually asked them to do the same
drink for me with two different tonics
the generic one and their $50 one and
you know I'm always scared that I'm
being affected by the knowledge of it
this why I love tasting everything blind
you like really want to know the score
do a double blind tasting not single
blind where you kind of know what the
five wines are or bourbons and they're
in bags double blind you have no idea
what the hell is being poured um but the
tonic thing fascinates me cuz it makes
sense right like if the quality is
higher it's the core component I get
cranky when people improve things that
don't need to be improved that's fair
the
waters you know when they offer you 17
different Waters I I like to go to a
restaurant and say I have a water
allergy what are you
serving what you were saying you know
however uh on the water side of things
you know when you're buying a bottle of
vodka you know almost 50% of what you're
buying is just the water they to cut
100% 290 proof down 100% so it it
matters and we're fortunate to be in the
Roaring Port Valley there where we get
Rocky Mountain Spring Water fabulous
water best water in the world and I
think that's a key component to to with
the whiskey and Bill how do people find
this I assume given it's smaller craft
you're probably and knowing how liquor
laws work in America I assume you're not
in all 50 states well now we we've tried
to grow uh smartly over time not too
fast in 24 States now I think we're in
all most of the states that matter you
know now the control for the 26 states
that are listening that don't matter
good news we're not going to break down
the states so you won't know if you live
in a state that matters or doesn't
matter keep going brother I'm playing
I'm play is it is it heavy on pre like
is it given the crafts of it is on
premise AKA restaurants and bars and
speak easys more than liquor stores or
in all those states that you're in it's
also readily or somewhat available in
liquor stores when you're building a and
of course you have to start on premise
get the liquor to the lips the pandemic
was a blow cuz all tough timing on
premise was gone gone and uh you had to
you had what about your direct to
Consumer business obviously liquor laws
continue to evolve and there's you know
20 years ago it was impossible for
something like this to ship now it's a
little bit you know there's more
conducive how how's that going by state
it's going good and there's more and
more providers coming all the time what
are your biggest now we're going to put
our business hats because we all nerd
out on this podcast about that what are
your biggest biggest states uh Cali well
we're based in Colorado Colorado number
one probably you know 70% of our
business makes it's going down
California's big uh for us Texas
Illinois Illinois huge you know than
what's what's going on in this
impossibly competitive market uh so
we're uh this is tough this is tough you
know I mean I I I I set it up for you to
have some vulnerability friends New York
City Boy and the challenge of it's hard
the liquor business for some for a
supplier like us is do you go with the
800 lb gorilla so let me let me give
everybody some context on this just like
every other industry there's incredible
consolidation last 50 years in the whole
sale business the people they sell it to
and those people sold it to people like
me and my dad um so now what you have in
Most states is you have one or two major
players which is great because they have
salespeople and infrastructure the
problem is for a brand like this is in a
world where those people are running a
business and they've got 50 cases or 100
cases they sell to them and they want it
in the best spots for that big company
they're selling a 100,000 cases of Jack
Daniels or this that you get lost in the
shuffle or then you can choose to go
with a little guy who's going to really
give a [__] but it's hard for that
person to break through to a lot of
these accounts because they're competing
and so it becomes a really interesting
really interesting game to play of
finding the right Partners who care
enough about you to care but also have
enough of juice on the selling side to
get into places luckily all we got to do
is get them to taste it well that's
right that's why this kind hence why 70%
obviously will go down over time in
Colorado you have all that
infrastructure for a lot more sampling
tasting flavoring that's exactly right s
trial yeah is everything in this
business it does sell itself it's finest
Spirits consumables yeah beverages
snacks cand
consumables everything is about
retention yeah so you can be the best
marker I you know I think we're very
good at what we do but when we meet with
companies I tell them sometimes when I
think they have a flawed product and you
know from a subjective point of view I'm
I've been wrong I'm a human being but if
I'm like this is not there yet I just
remind them great marketing just speeds
up everyone realizing you have shitty
[__] yes well put you know and so to
your point I very much understand Bill
I'm proud that it all comes from
Colorado too everything in the bottle
came from Colorado it came from a small
Distillery I don't know why that means
something to me but you know Blends by
the way I think local and Tera and craft
I think I think that is very romantic to
a lot of people it is to me um final
moments is there anything we didn't
touch on that you two hoped we touch on
before we get out of here I would hope
you touched William H ma let me
seey yeah this stuff yeah this stuff
gets
isn't it yeah I see it oh look at you in
there look at me look at you in the
river in the Woody Creek W Creek how uh
how serious did you take picking that
outfit CU it looks great tasting eight
barrels and uh with really Heavy Hitters
in the business these guys knew what
they oh no I'm not talking about the
product I'm talking about your outfit in
this picture oh I was freezing my gonads
off it was really cold that water comes
out of the mountains and I don't know
why it's not this is you picking one
specific Barrel that's what this blend
is and so one barrel produces how much
about 40 cases six six packs so there's
only 240 bottles in this a little bit
more no so our our Steels and fermentors
are capable of about three barrels per
Mash got it so this was one mashing so
there were three brother barrels uh they
all sampled the same but when we blinded
it I think Bill had we started with 14
and consistently we all blinded back to
this this m this 80 80 ride 20 mted
barley and uh it's phenomenal and again
we I was waiting until I could have a
tenure to really get up in the premium
yeah of lied offering of course and Bon
bond is certainly huge in the business
right now and huge Hunter prooof love it
blah blah blah Bill guys how do people
find this uh for everybody who's
listening around the world and Creek dis
stillers.com Woody Creek distiller.com
you couldn't have picked a longer name
yeah the emails can we can we can we
have that meeting after this podcast
wc.com yeah that the problem is that
costs a [__] lot of money ex might you
might have to do another movie and get
use some of the proceeds towards a a new
URL what dis stillers.com that's a lot
of [__] typing yeah but it's easy to
remember because what it is it's what
distillers and and uh anything else that
we should know about any uh back to lips
any vbl the price point it's the finest
Spirit you can buy in America and the
price point is very reasonable roughly
so for for the bucks for for the bourbon
and 54 for the r and what about public
events where people can actually taste
whiskey Fest this Thursday whiskey Fest
is where here in New York uh what is
today Tuesday let's see if we can bump
this up to tomorrow so this can go out
for the people that want to go and you
guys are going to be there yeah you're
going to be there bro you bet you can
take some selfies
yeah man thank you for being on you
brother best day thank you so
much